our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us this
morning we are highlighting the unlikely
bond between a police officer and a
young man whose father was in and out of
prison John Blackstone went to Orange
County California to meet the pair
growing up my father was incarcerated he
wasn't there actually incarcerated a
couple months before I was born and I
was in for a little over 10 years for
Daniel Rodriguez it could have all
turned out differently at an early age
lessons in law and order turned into
motivation there was no resentment about
law enforcement no honestly no never
once did I did I feel resentment I knew
they were doing their job and even then
when he was arrested they would come and
talk to us and comfort us it was never
just a job to them as a teen he joined
the police explorers program for
aspiring officers in Garden Grove
California south of Anaheim some kids
run into trouble you were running away
from trouble yeah I was I was trying to
I think I needed somebody to to vent to
about things and you know just make me
feel that much better going home and
knowing that I was able to talk to
someone about it that someone was
veteran officer and Explorer mentor
Jason Perkins who turned out to be a
good listener
Daniel and his mind selected me and I
had no choice in it it step up and be
that person in his life or turn and walk
away and I can't turn my back on on him
he guided Rodriguez through high school
there's you know things that beginning
years of high school not too proud of
and you know having Jason around and
being able to talk to him and you know
going through high school and you have
girlfriends and you don't want to talk
to mom about like oh my girlfriend Liz
my girl from that and later into the
police academy having Jason there has
moral support and kind of that backbone
of saying hey man you got this don't
worry about it like you need to believe
in yourself it had definitely helped out
a lot and Perkins was there alongside
his brother and mother latisha Macias to
pin on his badge at graduation he hasn't
just been a mentor for him he's also
been a great dear friend that male
figure he was lacking at home I will
forever be grateful for that somewhere
along the line you guys came up with
nicknames yeah he would always tell me
I'm not here to replace your father
but I think he he was able to fill that
boy of that male figure that I didn't
have going up and I don't know where
when or where it started and started
calling him pops he calls you pops
you call him mijo Spanish for son
he's the son I never had in every sense
of the word today
Rodriguez patrols the streets of nearby
Placentia right now leading his own
police Explorer program came full circle
for me working with the kids and trying
to do my best I'm mentoring them and
using me you know the skills that I've
kind of grasped from Jason and trying to
do what he's done for me for all the
other kids there's so many lives out
there that he'll have an impact on in
his career my career is winding down but
his is just getting started
so that's that's why I say he'll do a
hundred times what I ever did in my
career he'll do in his there's a big
task sounds like he has a lot more
confidence than you like it than I do
but you'll be fine he'll be fine for CBS
this morning John Blackstone Garden
Grove California